Speaker 1: Last Ron DeSantis discussion for
today, and then we're going to move on to some
other things. A completely and totally deranged
Ron DeSantis appeared on Fox and Friends and said
that if he is elected president, he will destroy
leftism, destroy leftism. Hmm. I think he might
actually believe this, which is the scariest part.
Speaker 2: Because right now, the time for Ron
DeSantis to run for president. Because
everyone knows if I'm the nominee,
I will beat Biden and I will serve two terms and
I will be able to destroy leftism in this country
and leave woke ideology on the dustbin of history.
Speaker 1: Okay. So that's the. If I'm president,
we will end chicken and waffles. It's just either
you want savory or you want sweet. But we're not
going to allow these leftists from New York City
to come in and tell us that you're going to put
maple sirup on fried chicken. It's just not going
to happen. And it will be left for the dustbin
of history. This is extraordinarily dangerous,
what he is saying. And there are about a dozen
different concerns with it. And I'm going to
tell you about some of them now. First of all,
yesterday I played a clip for you of Ron DeSantis
saying he'd consider pardoning Donald Trump. And
meanwhile, he's saying that he's going to destroy
leftism. From a purely tactical standpoint. I
don't see how you win a Republican primary. You're
losing to Trump by 30. By saying you'll pardon
Trump and only talking about Joe Biden. Now,
I know that we we've talked about this before.
We talked about it at the top of the show. And I
know there is disagreement in my audience about
the strategy of DeSantis running against Biden.
And the idea is, by the most positive spin we
can put on DeSantis, only talking about mostly
talking about Joe Biden right now is that people
who see him will see him as the nominee and will
then envision and imagine what it would be like
for him to run against Joe Biden rather than
seeing him getting chippy with Donald Trump.
They see him as the challenger to Biden and they
might say, oh, I can see this working better than
what it was like in 2020 when Trump ran against
Joe Biden. So the idea is to plant the vision in
the minds of voters of, hey, this guy could be the
nominee. This is what it would be like. However,
however, I don't see how just saying stuff like I
will destroy leftism and Biden is bad is going to
get Trump supporters to say, Maybe I will go for
DeSantis. And I also don't know how it's going to
bring in new voters into the Republican primary.
So as a strategy, I don't really get it. Second,
it's really important to remember with all of this
anti-woke stuff, most people are on the woke side,
not the anti-woke side, the leftism
that DeSantis says he will destroy.
Is increasingly what Americans believe. We
have numerous polls at this point. These are
not outlier polls in any way, which not by a
huge margin, but like 55 to 45, 57 to 43, 62,
40. When you ask Americans their views on what we
might consider issues of wokeness. Right. Views
on inclusivity. Views on trans people. Views on
drag shows and book banning and race relations
and these sorts of things. People, the country
is coming out on the side of Wokeness. And so.
DeSantis, maybe this would work in Florida. I
mean, in a sense it did, because he won by 19,
I believe it was in his reelection
campaign to governor. The math isn't there
for it working nationally. He says he's going to
destroy the movement that is the foremost movement
defending human rights right now. The Republican
Party is not the party of defending human rights,
economic justice, LGBT rights. Defending the
climate. Teaching kids critical thinking. I
could go on and on. That's the movement DeSantis
says he wants to destroy. So forget about. I don't
know that this will win him the primary. I don't
think that this will win him a general election
either. And then we get to the third aspect of
this. And this is really the saddest one and one
that is more in line with a lot of the things
we've talked about on this program. This is
a totally anti-intellectual argument, and I know
that the Republican Party has become the anti and
pseudo intellectual party. It's been this way for
decades. Instead of engaging with specific ideas
and trying to refute the evidence put forth by the
left, the left of which I consider myself a part,
the Santos is either interested or you might even
say, obsessed with just dismissing the entire left
outright. And the dismissive attitude is also
towards intellectual discourse. It's towards
higher education, it's towards learning and
thinking and epistemology and media literacy and
critical thinking and all of those things. And we
can say, Oh, it's because he's pandering to dumb
Republicans. Okay, yeah, there are Republicans
that are dumb, but the danger in it is that it
undermines the democratic process because it gets
people thinking about elections or better said,
not really thinking about them in ways that allow
the democratic process to be corroded, which we
saw on January 6th and which we've seen other
attempts made trying to overturn the election,
etc.. And then lastly. He's going to need. I
mean, listen, I don't know that I would say
DeSantis needs progressive support to win, but he
certainly needs moderate support. Probably sons,
some center left people who might say, I don't
really like Biden. And while the Santos is to
my right, I'm going to vote for him because he's
extending an olive branch and reaching out to me.
When you say I will destroy leftism, you blatantly
ignore and debase your progressive constituents.
And DeSantis in that way is going to shut himself
off from even maybe getting a little bit of that
voter base. He's limiting his voter base to the
most extreme elements of the Republican Party
and I guess like right leaning independents
maybe. But the open minded independents,
to the extent that they exist, left leaning
independents, centrist Democrats, some of whom
DeSantis might be able to pick up if he had a more
conciliatory tone, he's going to lose all of them,
without which they will destroy leftism. So right
now, DeSantis, his approach doesn't seem like a
viable approach to defeating Donald Trump to even
secure this nomination. And it certainly doesn't
seem like a viable approach to defeating Joe
Biden in the next couple of days and maybe even
by tomorrow in time for tomorrow's show, we will
have post announcement polling in a hypothetical
matchup against Biden. I'm curious to see what
that will look like. Make sure you're following
us on tick tock. We're we're approaching. This is
an unbelievable number. We are approaching half a
million tick tock followers. We have not grown
this quickly on any platform ever. Make sure
you're following us on tick tock and make sure
you're subscribed on the YouTube channel as well.